yeah so just be uh
just be wary of that
we're not streaming yet are we sonia
all right looks like we're not just
about be all
prison and correct
[Music]
yeah
okay
if we're all here
um we might just make a start
so kyota now my hiring my good afternoon
councillors it's great to um to have you
here all in uh
on zoom in front of me uh i'll declare
this meeting open and we don't have any
apologies that i'm aware of everybody's
here and correct so that's good
uh are there any
declarations of conflicts that
councillors wish to make at this point
in time
not so we'll move on then
um so we'll move on to confirmation of
minutes and reports and
we just have the one confirmation one
minute set of minutes to approve and
that is the minutes the ordinary meeting
of council held on tuesday 10 august
would somebody like to prove that as a
true and correct record please
counselor grant thank you
and secretary
council read thank you
is there any alteration
to that report required
there's not i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
thank you councillors
so we'll move on into
item
5 which is a correct
correction of the record from
two meetings ago when we hit a
discussion around
streets alive and the way forward there
and
uh going back and there was or there's
an item raised it's pretty
straightforward there i think but there
was an item raised
that
the minutes weren't quite reflecting the
conversation that happened at the
council meeting
um when the
minutes the record had been reviewed
it turns out that the minutes were right
we just needed to add on the barry
wiggin street
section and rather than taking anything
out
so um
it's open for discussion
any counselors wish to
make any comment there if not would
someone like to move that that
record would be corrected
counselor grant and second to council
phillips
no further discussion all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried
right um
creative community scheme
and we have a record of the meeting that
was held on the 30th of august
for
receipt uh would somebody like to move
that be received as true and correct
record
i'll move your worship
davis thank you do i have a second for
that councillor thank you
uh is there any discussion on that set
of minutes any questions
there's not i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
all right okay the motion is carried
thank you
right let's move on into
item seven
and one that has been a little bit
controversial
over the period um street's alive and
the streets are live
wrapper
and we have a
a
report here from the roading asset
manager peter standrum
before i hand it over to you peter
can i ask the chief executive if he
wants to make any
[Music]
opening comments on this particular
subject
not particularly your worship i think
all i would add is that um
it was
a very brave endeavor of the council um
and i think the
the council entered into the trial with
the
best possible spirit
um benefit of hindsight
the some of the
the extent of the activations were
challenging not just the community but
to the council
and obviously we were
an outlier in terms of other trials
tried around new zealand and um
which were far less extensive
and
it's i guess it's created a lot of
interruption and uh
some
deep sea seated feeling of angst in the
community we're now at a um a pause and
i guess it's been
a little bit disappointing to see that
waka tatahi has had now some funding
challenges which may
prevent
some of the more meritorious ideas that
came through this trial being able to be
implemented
in a timeline that would meet both the
councils and communities expectations
that's my sort of
um
overarching impression you worship
thank you steve um so peter
would you like to uh talk us through
your report and um
the floor is yours
i tried to actually give some sort of
balance i suppose with
where we started or from and where we
are now and where to from here
i try not to clog the essential message
up just with a six page report but a lot
of our background thinking
and consideration after the after effect
has been so captured in my appendices
later on with these
some of the findings that we've had some
of uh um was seeing thoughts some of the
things that we've learned
um a lot of this is actually what we've
had to develop for our report our case
study report that we're putting to nzta
wakatau is a wind-up to all of us
but um
certainly as there's been plenty of
opportunity to sit back and look at
things and balance of things that we
could have done better should have done
better by ourselves and ncta and that's
certainly being supportful for not just
myself but for the people i'm dealing
with throughout the country
uh with similar sort of sentiments
so i think the message is going to get
through um
executive is right they have had some
challenges with the follow-through or
they have had funding
uh secured for the second stage of
streets alive uh this is for rolling out
some sort of um
initiatives throughout the rest of the
country but also to help support
uh some of the go-to from here so except
exactly the extent of that or what's
actually available was used to be sort
of opened up it had been some challenges
of being cta with their funding and just
getting through some of the programs so
slowly getting our rest of our programs
out to us let alone but
the extent of this uh this later one so
uh working progress so like i'm happy to
leave it there and i'll take any
questions
okay i think um as a council
uh we we were
ambitious perhaps a little bit over
ambitious in terms of
the scale and the timing of the
of the program that was rolled out
however there has been quite a lot of
learnings taken from this and while
there are some some negatives there
there's also a number of positives that
as time goes on but
to discuss the report i'm going to open
it
for councillors to to make any comment
they wish at this point in time
and we need to decide on a way forward
council red
thank you your worship um i'd just like
to thank peter for a really um
reflective and comprehensive report i
think it's covered most of
everything that happened in a way
forward um um
one or two of the things that will be
implemented hopefully like the uh
the road markings and
things like that
you know i just think they've been um
really
made such a difference to the traffic
flow and just even the safety in the
town
one of the things i would like to see is
go ahead with and i know it wasn't
terribly popular but some of those
little courtesy crossings they're still
but they're actually being used now more
than they were through the trial um
which is a wee bit surprising but
every time i've been out in the
community i've seen people using them
so um
yes it's been a long hard road and a
winding road
but
there's been some positives come out of
it and one of the best positives was
actually the slowing down of traffic
particularly in some of the residential
areas and near the schools and some of
the comments that we've had from the
schools in the area um reflect that as
well
thank you peter and the contractors as
well they'll
put them
thank you bronwyn um yeah and i look i
eco the comments that you made and it's
interesting to read in the report
peter's put in uh some comments from
what he terms some of the quieter people
in
the project and and there is some good
stuff coming out while it got
um so firstly
doug
and then richard
[Music]
thank you worth it uh yeah i reiterate
uh councillor reeves um
what she said about
the way gore has actually it's flowing a
lot in here um i notice that in
particular i get around gore quite a bit
on deliveries and the roundabouts that
made it huge
uh the problem the big problem at the
moment is some people still don't know
how to use roundabouts
for people
[Music]
but they are getting used to it and uh
even on brown street you're realizing
that you got to slow down for the quick
program that was uh
when when uh speaker live did come out
it was quite controversial and uh
what's happened is
that
to get people out here in the community
whether they're biking or walking around
um timing wasn't good with us
you know we came out in the middle of
winter when we when we started rolling
this out
but it was intense to actually put
walking trails around uh people who had
play activation stuff we got
a street heart
trail going but there's also going to be
um a play trail
there's going to be um
or else was a big trail for a biking
trail that we had and i'm just getting
around areas of interest around town so
there's a number of wee activations like
that that we're working through with um
with the dhb and with uh southland
um
and the other question was um
on appendix day you've got uh earth
streaks
this day for the summer and second place
for a convention of co-design discussion
um
have we have we finished with our expert
because i thought the the small
committee that was uh finished after the
special life done we still hadn't we
were looking at taking out a couple of
items to put some card parts back in or
is
the champions together to see exactly
what we pulled there but i think the
understanding was that most of it was
going to be left to see through a season
um and also to help stimulate the
conversation and co-design but yes i
think i agree with aspects of it need to
be pulled out
and that's just a matter of timing the
bat and maybe getting getting a few hits
together we can decide exactly what and
when
okay so that was my understanding thank
you
thanks um thanks peter and doug richard
john yep
just just confirm your worship you can
hear me okay i can i was struggling a
bit with doug's i've had yeah i'm just
um
okay uh just through your worship to
peter our first extensive plan and
obviously we've done a fair bit of work
together
around um with that uh co-working group
and we're probably from the councillor's
point of view appreciate how much work
has gone in there
um and just to back up what council
reid's saying
um and we both tended to focus on the
positives um because it was a lot of non
uh constructive sort of things that
occurred during the period of time and i
think in the face of adversity we
probably got some um
some good wins out of it
so i'll complement the staff for that
um
i'll also point out that it was a
rigorous platform that we tried our new
media on too
uh something that um
let's talk and
uh that sort of thing so i think we
actually have had some small ones out
the other side uh using a major project
it was ambitious and
we actually uh probably got some
benefits from trying out um some of our
other systems because when you look at
the numbers that came through there it
was huge and i think that that's
obviously under our lessons learned um
obviously for the for the community it's
important that they note that in
appendix a there is still consultation
to come
around some of those street closures
because we're still getting people uh
querying regarding um some of those
closures and in the uh points in there
that it is there that is part of it it
hasn't finished
the other matters that came out of that
uh
looking at the stats
i think there's um some some huge work
we need to do around uh the increase in
traffic through gore you've got a 79
increase in the last year of traffic
exiting escort um you know that
there needs to be some digging into that
and seeing what's actually happening and
where things are traveling around that
that's going to drop out of this
um that's if i'm correct with those
steps there uh peter
suggesting that there's streets alive
were causing so much more traffic
through town um we went to nzta and
found out their statistics as we've got
displayed there and showed that over
here there has been a significant
increase of traffic through town and
yeah i'm quite happy to actually push
that back to him and saying things like
the intercession of childhood road and
state highway need to be looked at more
seriously because of the actual increase
we're receiving through town
i i believe on the stats that we have
there there's going to be further work
that'll drop out and it's another bonus
uh when we look at other um other
matters that have dropped out of the
street slide program
but um other than that uh the um we're
obviously still getting some commentary
and from the changes
and was laid on the ground in a very um
a very difficult environment and a
changing environment so i think
i think we've done well and the
consultation process should continue
with that group of councillors that are
interested in making sure this does
come to a successful conclusion or a
successful progression
uh doug is correct that in that
irk street sorry councillor grant's
correct that in that irk street
um discussion regarding co-design we are
looking at possibly um removing some of
those matters and creating parks but
we're also looking at possible access to
having temporary um
uh stand comes out for for certain
occasions like the uh festivals on
the music festival so i think there's
some
great stuff to come yet um but
that's my piece thank you
thank you richard and thank you for the
work that you and the other councillors
on that
working group have done and continue to
do and i think the the point you've made
well is that consultation is not
finished uh this is an evolving project
and we just need to
make sure that we're connected with
the whole community
john i think your hand up was next
you're on mute john
that guy now yep
um i just have a little bit of trouble
picking up some of the people speaking
or the internet's frozen up twice but
um just under the recommendations that
the council accept the proposed forward
work pro program of work i just want to
have peter can run through that
thanks
um going forward from here is getting my
report into ncta forming out
as as i've suggested in the report
there's a number of
installations that have been put in
recently permanently out there and
others that have been put in a very much
permanent sort of function until we hit
a sort of
a design done and funding to actually
put them in a permanent fashion
like some of our
roundabouts they probably need to be
formed up better we need some curbing
and some it wants to get a bit more
design work done
for that so it's actually getting a
whole program of work of the things that
we want to do around town and see
against utah you're prepared to fund
that we'll certainly see if council is
an agreement with all those changes
to a large extent is why things have
been left in the field and this is
actually where we intend to do something
of the permanent question
so
thanks peter um so in terms of the work
program going forward
uh is that has that been played out
clearly
um
i got i took from what you said then
that the next step is to go to nzta
and get their reaction
and then come back and
and finalize that work program is that
right
sorry i've got about our sequence
firstly is to program everything that we
have in the field there get the
agreement from council and then have
in conjunction with that oh we'll be
looking at ncta and seeing what's what
level of support we will get for any
program we put together
okay
so in terms of timing and sequencing of
that particular
piece of work
and will that come back to council
i'd suggest it would uh we've got a
working party um i'd like to sort of get
something to go forward from here
and then if we start our
program and then hopefully bring that
back to council
so in terms of the recommendation that
we have on page 22 look at this
um
should that be more
structured like
uh and the council develop the proposed
work
program going forward
rather than accept the work program and
for council approval
yeah
okay
um brahman and then uh glenna showed
your hand up and then neville
thank you your worship um i just
uh counsellor macphail made reference to
the street street closures i just wanted
for clarification's sake uh i presume he
was talking about the one-way changes at
equal street and maybe a change at the
bottom of broughton street
i don't i don't recollect any closures
being spoken about
uh three words to respond to this with
the report discussing there's still a
consultation in regard to where we've
done those changes and
accessing echoes from
main street
and matters that that had been changed
in mid-stride during our
streets alive and that we still
agreed amongst the working group that we
were going to go to consultation
to see what the public feeling was in
regard to that
okay
okay um
neville oh sorry no glimmers never
well thank you worship um
yes i'm pleased to hear that we're going
to consultation regarding um the end of
vehicle street brown street richard
thank you for clarifying that
um
my question is there's a lot of people
have asked me about those polls that are
on the road with red
red around them um are they going to be
taken away and something more permanent
put there because they are
a bit of an eyesore i feel
um
yes that was really just my question
thank you
so so peter on that one my understanding
is that
those
stand stand ups in the in the middle of
the road are a temporary of a temporary
nature and that whatever is designed
there going forward will be quite
different to that is that wrong
um correct it would be more likely uh
obey that we have a little bit uh refuge
island the reason we haven't taken it
away is that we are getting people who
are using these and giving us um
i guess giving them a lot of relief
having that refuge island in the middle
so i didn't necessarily want to take
away and we've agreed that that's not
happening but
certainly ones i'm going to suggest that
we do have crossings out
but we have um zebra crossings as well
as
and um
rather than the courtesy crossings i
think people would understand
clearly what they were there for in
those um some of those high
used areas
i guess that's something i don't want to
put words in your mouth but i guess that
that'll be something that's subject to
the proposed um
plan of work going forward what um
what what those crossings might look
like
it's i found it quite interesting
reading the report
feedback that's come from
some of the high use areas particularly
around schools and what it is
the courtesy crossings have been
celebrate it as as being a success but a
lot of the feedback i've had from
general public is that they cause
confusion so i think we just need to get
a bit more clarity
on on that
uh sorry peter i jumped on you okay
thank you
okay uh nibble
yeah thank you worship i just got a
question for peter um if we were
unsuccessful with what qatar getting our
funding for our proposals
for the comparament changes have you got
anything in your budget or
where do you see us situated
with uh without their funding
uh free worship the eca as much as
australian for funding are suggesting
that by spending 28 percent up to 28
on
cycling um and pedestrian facilities
around the country which is a real
strong message man this is this is
direction we're going so so yes i have
actually got some funding for
uh pedestrian facilities both for path
pathways and crossings for around town
anyway so
part of
streets of life could be funded through
that but i am looking for stress loss to
fund specific funding first i still
really want to explore that
thank you
just got a one more question for peter
then thanks for watching
in regards to that the imperial does um
well you have a budget set
out when you put your proposal through
to ngta well we
have to see that budget just in case we
don't get the funding
correct i'm all too happy to have what
we have available for us right now and
what extra would be uh needed and have
in front of council and
see where the taste is to take that
forward right now to actually step out
of number gears
okay thank you very much
thank you um so brett did you have a
question or a comment
yeah thanks for watching i think it's
largely been answered around the
recommendation in the proposed work
program but i guess i'm just keen to
understand the interaction between the
working group and full council what is
the brief of the working group there's a
working group going to form up some
recommendations to come back to full
council because i think
one of the lessons to be learned here is
that i think we all need to be on the
same page and understand what's going to
be delivered
to the community
is there are no working group reports up
or has it got power to act i know their
parents are disestablished and modified
but where to from here
i think one of the learnings that we can
take from this particular trial is that
we need to be as connected to both
council
and the community as we possibly can be
and and staff as well so yes i would
envisage that it would come back to
council but unless somebody's got
another idea
is that what you're thinking about peter
most definitely is
just working through uh
um the issues that we have around the
streets the proposals that we have and
getting something firmed up and being
taken back to council with some uh some
costings and that program and then some
costings associated okay
um
so dennis did you
have your hand up there for a minute
no thank you okay great
okay um so
what i take from that is that
we're looking for council to receive the
report
and to prove that
work can continue on
to develop a program
going forward which will then come to
council
am i correct in that thinking
yes
yes sorry
okay would somebody like to move in that
direction please
so councillor reed you're moving that
way and secondary council follow-ups
thank you
is there any
further discussion required
it was not i'm going to put that motion
all those in favor please say i
against the motion is carried thank you
right we'll move on then to item eight
uh uh rescue helicopter trust funding
and we have a report here from the chief
executive
a report that
started its life at the southern mural
forum
where a request was made to all of the
councils in the south to help support
the air ambulance trust
we have as a council i believe
considered this in the past and decided
it wasn't their role
however the the call is getting louder
i'd have to say
and
and i noticed that the use of the
helicopter and our community is getting
more and more frequent than than i've
ever seen before in fact i've been woken
up a few times um since the
helicopter appears to have a flight path
quite
close to my house that um in the middle
of the night
of the helicopter coming in
and
and i believe there's some real voting
and in terms of
leadership in the community to be
connected to this in some way or another
chief executive has put together a
report and i'm going to ask him to
speak to that at this stage
yeah thanks your worship there's not
much more i can add to apart from the
fact that there was strong support for
this uh request at the mineral forum
a hundred thousand dollars constitutes
there or there abouts one dollar per
head of population in southland
um and i think most of the no if not all
mayoral form forum members
uh were
acutely aware of the importance of the
first hour in terms of medical need
as this worshiper said
the rising use of helicopters
and
probably a lot of people have had
someone they know or close to that has
benefited from the service and i think
that the southenders in the mirror forum
they felt that they're benefiting from a
service not contributing to it and
that's not really the southern way
and so there was a real
mood of look we need to help this trust
continue to offer this vital service to
to southland and our neighbours otago
i can also report your worship that as
far as i'm aware neither the south and
or invocable city councils have yet
formally requested consider this request
but the formula i set out my report was
loosely banded about at the
forum meeting
and is cons generally consistent with
the
very various populations that
each council has or services
thank you steve so um john
and then
john can you hear me
might be frozen isn't it
so brahman do you want to um
thanks your worship um
i think we should make clear that this
is the queen's the lakes district
helicopter that's asking for support um
they need to fundraise 600 000 a year to
cover the costs that aren't met by
government funding
i went online to find what data they had
to
um in our area but i actually couldn't
find any but the
targo air ambulance in over a month has
had 13 plus visits to southland hospital
and
another 11 between tiana down to rural
pokey
[Music]
so
i think for the amount of money as as
the chief executive said you know a
dollar a year per person we don't even
though possibly they're not coming to
gore um
that often
a lot of our people travel on the roads
we all move around we have some people
have homes in wanaka queenstown
so i'm
quite in support of this
i think because of the fact that they
have to fundraise for such a lot of
money and technology is changing so much
that
equipment is constantly having to be
replaced as well and there's the
maintenance as well so
i would be in support of this thank you
so um
just correct me if i'm wrong on this one
but there is a bit of confusion about
the lakes helicopter trusses
[Music]
and the otago helicopter trust is the
flies the machines that you see coming
into into this district
i believe that the lakes district air
rescue trust is primarily a fundraising
vehicle for that
for that service
um so
but it is a little bit unclear in my
mind
thank you
council reid uh councillor phillips
you're still on mutiny yeah thank you
your worship now i've just got a uh i
was actually uh councillor reedus asked
the same question i was going to ask him
and the fact is that um how many how
many flights does
the um
lake stick to actually do underwear into
our district and it's not many compared
to otago
but i ask the question is that um if
they were if they were serious about the
fundraising how um they should have
actually put in submissions into our
grants uh submission and
uh come through that come through that
avenue and i think um
i think they'll be more receptive if
they went through that avenue rather
than going through the mural forum and
if they did that i'll be more supportive
your worship
okay look i think the uh the issue was
raised with the mayoral forum
regional perspective
and there was a
very strong
support message given from the forum and
each of the councils agreed to take it
back
to their particular councils at that
time
and it was past the
the ltp
program now i know that this
is is probably not convenient in terms
of
um process
of our processes
however from my perspective
this is something that is a
pretty important and it's not urgent
need
to make sure that we we support
the endeavors of all the services that
provide help to our community when they
most need it
yeah think of your worship well oh don't
get me wrong i agree on the principle of
the thing but what i disagree with is
that lakes district do not fly because
they haven't got the contract to fly
into this to the southern area to
support helicopter flights for patients
out of out of their area
and i must rather support the otago one
rather than the south of one because
they have more flights in and out but
that's uh a question that that uh like
today is that for debate thank you yeah
and and there's a point i was trying to
make before obviously i didn't make it
very clearly my my understanding is that
the lakes district rescue trust is a
fundraising vehicle for the otago
operation
so there's there's a very strong
connection between
the two entities they're not they're not
competing entities
they're very much in cooperation
thank you worship um my understanding is
the largest percentage of the region is
that service
by the lakes district
um air rescue trust this is the lakes
district and um
the southern ocean the ski fields and
and the um tracks like the great walks
and
i do know that the otago helicopters is
funded by the ministry of health and
partially by saint john's
so i'm i'm just wondering why and that's
that's for our hospital transfers
so i'm wondering why your district is
putting funding into um the lakes
district
air rescue helicopters although i do
know that we do walk tracks and do
things like that but it
it seems to be a little bit out of our
area
but i think um
thank you
i think what um what is developing here
is there's some confusion around who
delivers what and who pays for it
and the processes and and i don't want
to
to make that even less clear by
saying again what i said before but i
think probably the way forward might be
to get jules tapper to come and speak to
this council
in person i think it does need to be
some clarity around this
but what i can say
and assure everybody is that
the entities that deliver
health services via helicopter are all
working very closely together and they
are not fully funded by any man or means
and yes the government do put some
funding in and yes and john's put some
funding in
but there is a gap
and
i guess at the end
the gap has to be met by by community
that's and that's generally what happens
across the country
um but i think probably it would be a
good idea if councils agreeable that we
invite mr tava to come and speak to us
so that we get a clearer understanding
of the
of the structure
and the
performance
in terms of
entering and exiting
our district
so
doug do you have a question there
yeah thanks your worship um that was
exactly what i was going to oh um
firstly can you is more microphone
better than much better right okay so uh
so just for interest sake it was to do
with these things don't use earpods when
you're on a zoom meeting okay
you're better off going hardwire like
i'm doing now because because it affects
your microphone system
so and councillor um heisted enlightened
me on that one
yeah the the air rescue trust here it is
a little bit confusing because lakes
district air rescue trust um and and
you're right tracy um the
um
i believe the otago regional helicopter
services have the contract with dhb and
then they subcontract it to the lakes
district air trust to do the fundraising
and southern lakes helicopters do all
the stuff south of
new zealand and
the ski fields and all that but it would
be um i was just going to ask for either
a further report by the ceo but i think
your idea
your worship is to get jules tapper in
and have a explain a whole lot that
would be a lot better and then we can
move forward on this report
uh and john you hit your hand up too
you're on mute chain too
yeah i missed most of it i fell off the
uh i fell off the end of the earth
um so i had the same problem i think
you know it is the same question i
knew it was already asked i noticed the
otago regional um gale helicopters the
regional council from otago support them
by 350 000
and the lakes district trust don't have
a list of supporters they have a list of
supporters but don't have the amounts
that they support and the only council
that supports cena's queenstown lakes
council
and um
so think i was questioning really are we
backing the wrong horse
well look i think it would be useful to
have
um jules come and speak to us because he
works very closely with graham gales
um okay is council comfortable with it
he's got his chains on and he's sitting
okay
um
right so that being the case um
would somebody like to recommend that we
we go down that track and that we invite
um
the representative from the lakes
district air rescue trust to come and
speak to council
directly
so council dixon segmented
council uh
macdonald thank you
all those in favor of this hour against
the motion is carried thank you councils
right it brings us on to
chipping of trees at the goron matera
landfill sites and we have a report
and of course
administration officer neil
fulsome report neil do you wish to speak
to that at this point
uh no your worship i think
if there's any questions i'll answer
them
accordingly oh okay it's open for
discussion counselors
so counselor
it's a bit of a side question and it may
have already been answered in previous
discussion but it just strikes me
viewing the sites hamilton park and the
like that there's a lack of an amenity
planting buffer between
the um
the gum trees that were that were taken
down and chipped and and this is just
not this is stage one of several years
of planting and chipping so i'm just
interested neil is there through your is
there any plan to have a amenity
planting to to um ensure that we don't
have a
a uh
a um
you know it's like a bit of a disaster
site every year we check this thing
sorry through your worship um i've been
talking to keith mcgroby on the subject
of the replanting of that area
and he thinks he can push it forward
um from what we originally took talking
about
but um no firm discussion has been head
um exactly when that will start just
once we've got a couple of areas that
they can start planting in which is
come this summer um
we can actually have some area that
would be able to be replanted
sorry neil i guess i was asking is it
going to be 100 gum trees that are going
to be clear filled and chipped in the
future or is there going to be some
beautification buffer planting around it
so we
we shield it in some way in the future
um through your worship um
i
still don't quite understand what you're
asking bret the idea was to replant the
natives
so all that area um both sides of the
the
walking track um along that through the
middle there will be a natives
eventually
sorry three words i understood that that
gum trees and and chipping was was going
to happen for
another couple growing seasons to build
a
build an organic matter base above the
landfill especially at hamilton park
um
it just seems we had quite a high level
of amenity at hamilton park i can't
speak from the terrace to the material
side but now we've got you know a clear
field area so
so just uh with regard to this it does
appear to be a little bit of a cross
purposes there steve do you have any
comment on this one
can you help us here
um
yeah you wish i think the
uh my understanding from uh council
heisted's question is
if there's going to be further chipping
is there going to be some amenity
planting to
shield that unsightly activity
um and
neil mayer has said there's no intention
to plant further gum trees and there has
been a quite a long standing objective
of native planting in that hamilton park
area
to
bring both
bird life into the um
the urban setting and also provide
the amenity
values that council heisted is concerned
about
so
i'm not sure about further
once my understanding is once the blue
gums have been cleaned up completely
it's full speed ahead in terms of
native planting
and retiring that area as
as an amenity area and not a future
logging site if that's what council has
did us concerned about
thanks steve i guess i'm just
really reflecting on the conversation
that ian sabre
the previous parks reserve manager
explained to me so i'm on a tangent
that's going into natives now great
so um
dennis
thank you worship um i'm just wondering
if there's any thought about
selling the trees for firewood because i
do understand there's
quite a lot of people looking for wood
stains for firewood
and
also
i also know that cools do chipping and
they do it at no cost and just take the
chips because there's a
um there's a market a good market for
them with dairy farmers
just wondering if those have been
considered
through worship the whole purpose of
failing the gum trees
was because of their instability but
also to create chips for
coverage over the old landfill
um we've done pothole testing right
through we've identified the areas that
have got less than 600 millimeter cover
over the low
landfill
and we've been spreading out
and also shifting chips to the areas
that need more coverage
and exactly the same is going to happen
down at matera
thank you as far as sorry as far as the
uh logging goes yes we do have people
asking and just this morning i was down
at matera there because some people have
been going and cutting up firewood down
there
it becomes a health and safety issue we
allow anybody into those areas just for
cutting up firewood
i was just meaning maybe for one
contractor to go in there and take them
out i think they're quite high value at
the moment
yes but the purpose of it was to get
that chip so we can actually close areas
off once we've got that adequate
coverage
thank you thank you so it sounds like
there's been a particular purpose for
those chips anyway um
thank you your worship just a question
from to neil um thanks very much neil
great report um i look forward to seeing
um
the uh work at the end of the month and
i know coverts probably hit hit pretty
hard in that aspect of time framing but
um
yeah that was my concern about the
residents going and cutting the firewood
with the logs that are still lying on
the ground
um
if you
had any uh
success in stopping them or are they
just sneaking and doing it
um as of this morning we've put uh
danger keeping up tape across the
gateways uh john clearwater that he
grazes a sheep there he's unaware as to
who is
um
gaining access
so
i do get the feeling with talking some
down there some locals don't want to
tell me who's doing it but
hopefully they'll take notice of the
danger key belt
signage
and as far as the time frame
goes i was just discussing it with
bradley york yesterday
and his new chipper is still due to
arrive
on the 24th of september down here in
southland um he's checked since the
covert lockdown and it hasn't delayed so
he's still being promised by
the supplier and
he is hope hoping to be into matera by
the end of september which will clean up
the
previous environment south and stuff at
the same time
through your worship thanks very much
that sounds really good and i do believe
that the people that are cutting up the
firewood are coming from their back
sections coming through the gate not
through the gate
um just
in a situation where two trees that come
down over the weekend with the wind
um but
there is also another tree that has been
felled from the property over into the
council property
has been cut down so somebody's taken
the opportunity to
fill their own tree
all the logs are still lying there
where the chance go by um but i think
it's good to get your report neil and
and it's going to be even better to see
both those sites cleaned up and
looking in the state that they have been
in the past rather than a bit of a bomb
site which is what they have been
through for some time
neville you had a question yeah yes
think of your worship neil if
if the chipper is not uh here in in its
time frame is it possible to at least
cut down the the trees that are standing
that the sheer
that the shear machine couldn't cut down
so at least take that iso away from
there to actually lower them onto the
ground is it possible or not uh well i
spoke to bradley uh yesterday and he
thought that he would be able to do
something but in the same breath he was
basically telling me that the chipper
will be there at the same time so
yes in another week i'll check with them
as to
ensure that that arrival time of the
chipper is going to be before the end of
the month
thanks very much neil much appreciated
that's right
okay so it's no further questions or
comments if there's not would somebody
like to move the receipt of the report
please
move council phillips stop a second
after that
all right councilman chanel thank you
emotional those in favor please say aye
against the motion is curved
thank you councils
well that brings us on to item 10 which
is the annual report on dog control
policies and uh practices and we have a
report
from the chief executive
and steve do you want to talk us through
this
yeah thanks your ship it's a fairly bog
standard report it's one that we are
obligated to provide on an annual basis
to the department of internal affairs
about dog control activities
uh in the
year previous year was in this case the
year ending fitted june
2021
there's nothing really remarkable in
this uh it's i think if you were to cast
your eye back
three or four years you would find a
similar level of activity and issues uh
occurring uh each year
and
i just
recommend our staff though who do a very
good job in very trying circumstances
where
i say that most dogs are under effective
control and it's usually about five
percent that cause about uh well a lot
a five percent that probably cause
eighty percent of the issues uh and
sometimes our staff have to
make difficult decisions and engage in
difficult conversations and i always
wanted to say that they do that
to a very good degree and
i believe the district has been well
served by their efforts
all right so the report is open for
discussion i think that it's um as chief
executive said it's pretty
straightforward
um
but if anybody has any questions or
comments at this point now's the time
otherwise
uh if somebody would like to receive a
move that we receive and adopt the
report counselor
you're moving
okay
senator council grant thank you
there's no further comment all those in
favor please say aye against the motion
is careful thank you
right
it brings us on to item 11.
three waters reform and
we have a letter here from um
your guardian
with regard to three waters reform
and i'm sure that as time goes on this
is going to be a regular
uh subject on our council agenda it's
certainly a subject that is occupying a
lot of my time it's occupying a huge
amount of time of
executives and elected members right
across the country getting an
understanding of
what the
proposals are and what the impact is
likely to be on on individual councils
up and down the country
but
mr gardiner has got some
straightforward views on how this
council should deal with
the particular reforms
personally i believe that we have
to excuse the pun there's a little bit
of water to go under the bridge on this
particular issue
before we get to a point that we can
make a decision in the very best
interests of this particular community
however
i share some of the concerns that that
he raises
and and i know that the concerns that he
raises are shared by
quite a number of people in this
community and and others across
the province so
uh is open for discussion uh and or
comment from councillors
council grant
thanks your worship
although i do share some of the
sentiments from mr gardiner's letter
um
do we
how how does mr garden get into our
agenda when
wouldn't this be a submission
or do we just allow
leaders to to come on on things that
we're discussing
because in theory
i don't know i could be totally wrong
but i thought that would be
[Music]
open for submissions or something we
haven't done anything like that uh we
don't know we we haven't gone down the
avenue of discussing this as as the uh
ce's report says that and as we're
moving along but we have a letter here
from from mr gara which is well written
later
in any ca any uh
member of this community can request the
premier councillors to consider a letter
on any subject of the insole oh okay and
this particular letter came from uh
council from mr gardon
and uh requesting that this be put on
the council agenda
uh certainly given the
topical nature of this particular issue
i thought that there is no reason why we
shouldn't um air it at this point in
time however in saying that and and
you've already said it we've still got
quite a lot
of work to do on developing a response
and we need to do that systematically
and methodically
to make sure that we get it right for
our community
and each community needs to do that
individually
because we are not the same as
queenstown and we're not the same as
westland we're not the same as one array
we're not the same as wellington and we
just need to make sure that we get this
right
for gore district
so but in terms of uh a
member of the community
requesting
uh something be placed before the
councillors
uh i've got no problem with that at all
okay
steve do you want to make a comment on
that thank you for that
i think you summed up while you worship
i think as worship said uh any member of
the public has the right to seek
um
that
a letter be placed on the agenda not
always does that request uh granted
because sometimes it can be dealt with
operationally
um or is not deemed to be
um
of sufficient um importance it needs to
engage all councils but as worship said
this is a debate that is raging across
the country um so on balance i thought
it was worthy of inclusion in the agenda
um and and it gives an opportunity for
the council to
alert the public that it isn't uh
a sleep of the will and that as actually
taking it's time to um brief itself on
the issue and of course we've got the
workshop planned for
uh this coming thursday which will be
followed by uh the council will have to
meet in a public setting to uh form an
indicative view
to then relay to the government by the
end of september
but
for the benefit of anyone reading or
listening that indicative view is just
that indicative and is not represented
of the wider community view which will
no doubt have to be the subject of some
engagement
but as the information has yet to all be
laid on the table
for councils it's difficult for councils
to have that conversation with the
community
[Music]
thank you for that yeah this this
particular subject has been
on the go now for several months it
hasn't just popped up and and i'd have
to say
there's been a number of uh items of
correspondence have come across my desk
and i'm sure that councillors will have
had them uh as well but i think we're
getting to the pointy end of this
discussion we're not there yet
but we're certainly nearing it
and and i think having um having a
letter like this
on the agenda is is good
to make sure that we're attuned to how
our community is um seeing this
uh and also to inform other members of
the community that might be interested
and aren't quite as aware as some others
okay so it's open for discussion and or
uh receipt
and i think and i think that um
from certainly from my perspective
a response a suitable response to mr
gardone would be that when we have
developed an opinion
uh we'll certainly share that
with them
any counselors wish to make any comment
counselor i told you now you wish it was
to speak i think
yes your worship um i don't think
council's in a position to hold a local
referendum on the matter particularly
our central government still
appears to be in a state of flux as to
the
um
magnitude and intent of uh the direction
it wants to take um and we're certainly
not in the position to
be able to form uh a uh a form proposal
which we would
couch a referendum around uh i would
agree with mr garden on seven that
appears to be a certain amount of
disquiet but about proposal on certain
amount of caution certainly from
ourselves and the local government up
and down the country and and uh on the
strength of that i think um i'd like to
move that we received mr gardiner's
letter with with thanks
okay so we've got a motion to have a
second up there counselor dixon thank
you
uh any further discussion
just not put that motion all those in
favor please say hi
gates the motion is carried thank you
so it brings us to item 12 and we have
an item with regard to street trees in
the main street of gore
and
we have a report here from our new parks
and recreation manager keith mcrobe and
uh keith with us today welcome along
keith to your first i think this is your
first council meeting thank you yeah
yeah it's good to have you um in the
community and a little bit of
interaction with keith uh to date on a
couple of projects and
i think he's going to fit in well so
look forward to
working with you as as time goes on
so
keith do you want to talk us just
through the report
um why are we even considering this at
this point in time and take us through
to where your recommendations are and
then discuss it
yep certainly certainly um
i think um
this issue came up before
council i think about three or four
years ago and and and there has been
some ongoing um
dialogue with between officers and um
i guess retailers in the main street and
there's obviously been some concerns
about um
i guess the leaf leaf drop as but but
also the size of some of the trees and
also the damage um
and and particularly on the uh
on the town site on the hillside of the
main street
um for some reason uh
the
the trees have grown seem to have grown
larger on the um
on the on the hillside of the main
street and um
there are also the trees that are under
um
under overhead wires so um
they have the trees on that side of the
road have been had some pruning going on
um
i think in terms of
uh
tree choice
um hindsight is a wonderful thing but
[Music]
the the meta sequoia in particular is is
the same tree family as the sequoia or
the sequoia dendrin which um
are the largest trees in the world
potentially so um
so it's it's
you know i guess in hindsight you would
say it's a slightly unusual tree choice
for the main street but um
certainly um in the 70s right through to
[Music]
um uh
early 2000's they were a popular tree
choice and um this particular tree
was uh um
i think
they thought it was a bit of a missing
missing link or a fossil specimen so
when it was discovered in china um
became very popular um
all around the western world really so
um and gore is no exception
to to that so um so essentially um the
trees on the river side of a street
i think are all in reasonably
good shape and they haven't um they
haven't been constrained by
any issues with overhead services so
they're they're less of a problem
um
the other thing was a couple of trees
outside the
bnz
and
again
however zelkova was quite a popular
street tree um and a lot of councils
but um
i think that the two specimens they have
grown particularly well and um
become quite dense in the canopy so
if it perhaps was a wee bit more open
they wouldn't be an issue but
one in particular is a real issue from
nzta's point of view in terms of
obscuring
a major sign um heading north so
so um
our recommendation is that there's uh
three of the
um
meta sequoia on the
hillside of a main street uh be removed
and
[Music]
one of the zell covers which which is
which is a request request from nzta so
quite quite happy to discuss um
um
in any aspect of that really
thank you keith uh and i think the
report is pretty straightforward
um you suggest in the recommendation
that um this would be some community
consultation along the way
so
did you have anything envisaged in your
mind as to what that might
look like
um
no i haven't actually i haven't given
that a lot of thought but um yeah no i
think um that that it's valid you know i
think i think the retail point of view
i've you know i have spoken to a couple
of retailers on the main street and um
i think their view is probably quite
clear but
but i think yeah we need we need to
go beyond that too
okay
okay thanks keith uh so open for
discussion and or question don't you
hear uh
thanks your worship um
yeah uh welcome to the gdc keith um i
haven't actually met you yet but i'm
sure we'll
cross paths at some stage well written
report thank you very much
very easy to follow uh it was good um
and um you've given us uh
the not the trees that um you have
suggested recommended to come out as
well as what's going on
um
the trees in the main street uh have
been
a bit of a
uh discussion over the last number of
years and we've had uh various retailers
uh one in particular bmw sports use is
not there anymore but he was very vocal
uh
brought it to uh
brought it to the council to uh to see
if we can get rid of them um a number of
years ago so
he will be jumping up and down when he
hears uh here's your report but um my
question a couple of questions the
malice tsinoski is that how you
pronounce it yes yeah yeah uh which is
the pillar uh crab apple two two
questions is it deciduous is the first
question the second question is can we
get crab apple jelly from it
um i i think it's it's it's really an
ornamental um specimen and it it's
probably what you would call a
medium-sized tree so um shouldn't
shouldn't present uh too many issues in
future but uh
the other thing is it it is deciduous so
there will be some leaf fall um but it
is um it does have nice autumn color
and and also flowers in the spring so
yeah
okay so it's not it's not a crab ever
would you can't get crab levels from no
okay
all right so i'm pretty sure that the
leaves will be a lot easier to handle
than that
than the ones that are dropping because
the things that drop at the moment they
just go all over the street and they go
into the uh they tend to blow into
sterling sports not sterling sports b b
sports doorway and also a hundred
percent electrics all down through there
so i'm pretty sure you're gonna have
some happy people
thanks for your report cheers
thank you and welcome keith
um i'm no supporter of cutting down
trees as you probably all know but i can
see that these are causing a problem
um
and i would support what you're doing
but wondering um if if you had
considered putting
maybe a negative trees in there like
coughing
um
to be fair to answer your question no no
we haven't and and i do support the use
of kofi because it brings them to birds
but um i i guess that's potentially
another issue but um
certainly um
they they are they are quite a a good
street tree really so you know certainly
have used them in omarou and a couple of
other places so yeah
thank you
i guess some of that could be picked up
in consultation
and i think
just in terms of consultation the point
that doug raised around
the retailers that are on the east side
of the main
street i think there's it does need to
be some work done there because there
has been
um
while there's no power lines there um
there has been a number of issues that
have been raised with me over the years
about the way they block gutters um
spoutings spouting some monavie um in
the past so
as long as that can be kept in mind
um i throw it through your worship i can
possibly comment on that one um i have
instructed my staff to go through and
basically take the low whirl of um all
the remaining um meta sequoias up so
essentially that that allows you to um
see the the shop front banner which um
so i think that will be received you
know reasonably well and it you know it
won't have any
sort of ill effect on the tree but um
certainly just
allows a bit more light and and um
yeah helps that one thank you
um so
neville and then brett
thank you worship
uh just a question um
in regards to the removal of the trees
have you thought about uh what the three
waters might be like underneath the
surface
and do we do them
upgrade them
before we put replant the trees and
re-just redis
re-develop the plots again or
because i think some of that uh pipe
work under that under that side of the
uh street is quite old i know that the
east side was um had new pipeline but
i'm not sure about the
the west side
um i think
an answer to that one we haven't uh we
haven't looked at the underground
services and and i suspect there will be
some issues but um
i i recently did a bit of work um
[Music]
from a contracting point of view um
in queenstown um
we've been putting a lot of um
i guess i guess large street trees into
their streetscape and they're using a
system called strata cells and you know
i would think we should probably go go
with that and basically it allows the
tree to um
tree roots to develop better but a bit
also it does it doesn't give you the
issues with all the heaving of a surface
that
you would get with a
tradition traditional street tree so
so i think if we
go through that process
we'll get a reasonably good outcome
thanks keith but it's not answering my
question you worship in the gardens to
uh is there a program set set
for us to look at the infrastructure
while the trees have come down is there
does the infrastructure need replaced
uh while the trees are down before new
ones grow on top of them again that's
the question i ask
if i can assist the meeting you worship
i think that's something that's probably
best
asked of our three waters manager about
what we can do he's not i don't think
he's on this
zoo meeting
i can ask matt bayless the three waters
manager to liaise with keith with a view
to
any improvement works that dean needed
that can be done while the trees are
down and before a new specimen is
planted
but thank you mr perry that's that's
answered my question thank you
great
thanks your worship um
yeah thanks for your report keith it
seems to be a practical approach i guess
i've got a question for you worship for
the chief executive
being part of the panel that was put in
place
three years ago i think councillor davis
bulger and myself found ourselves
nominated to a panel uh receiving
submissions arborist reports and very
constrained and hands tied as to what we
can do
quite
in quite contrast to what we're seeing
today this is probably the right
solution but we simply couldn't deliver
that so just interested to know what has
changed is this because now we have an
issue um
as opposed to request from the public
yeah through your worship this is
because our tree policy does
specifically provide for tree removal if
they're causing damage to infrastructure
uh and this is clearly the case uh so
they are ill-suited the environment
they're causing damage to the
surrounding footpaths and therefore
under the tree policy the parks and
reserves mounted recreation manager is
entitled to authorised removal but
obviously um common sense dictates it
will consult with the community but
so this is not just
an issue of a tree's a bit awkward or a
bit ugly and a bit inconvenient this is
causing damage to infrastructure
therefore has got um i guess an elevated
right of removal than what normally
would be the case
thank you
okay
um any further questions or comments um
for keith
and his report um if it did not would
somebody like to move the recommendation
or the recommendations
uh and
somebody seconded it thank you so stuart
you want to
move that and don't give a second
thank you
okay i'll put that motion all those in
favor please
against the motion is carrick thank you
councillors so that brings us to the end
of the open section of meeting and i
think i neglected right at the beginning
to say that we had an item of urgent
like business that needed to be
discussed and i apologize for that if i
did neglect to mention it
but we do have one item of urgent late
business that needs to be discussed
and it's relating to the appointment of
an assistant electoral officer
for the council
to deal with
the upcoming referendum for the otama
water scheme
and
i think that does need to be discussed
in committee
so would somebody like to move that that
urgent item be received
uh and discussed at the end of the end
committee section
on movie worship so move counselor bulge
you're seeing the council guard on thank
you
is there any discussion
does not put the motion all those in
favor please say aye against the motion
is carried
right so that brings us to the end of
the open section of the moving i will
now move that the public be excluded
from the following parts of the
proceedings of the meeting
and the items below that we will be
discussing a confirmation of the minutes
of the ordinary
meeting of council held on 10 august
confirmation of the extraordinary
meeting of council held
tuesday 31 august confirmation of the
minutes of the capital works program
capital works committee held 18 august
and
consideration of
race resurfacing contract
for the council campground and the gore
library and community rooms
redevelopment
would somebody like to second that
motion please